[music]
Wow, it's wild to be on the same stage
as so many people I've drawn inspiration
from. Let's dive into it. My name is
Nick. I'm the head of AI at Klein and
today I'm going to share some lessons we
learned along the way.
So let's start with the bitter truth.
For years we compensated for weak models
by building clever scaffolds around
them. All kinds of clever ideas like rag
indexing systems, search trees, tool
calling scaffolds, all this was invented
to cope with weaker models. And Frontier
models simply bulldoze those
abstractions. Now, you don't really need
your scaffolding anymore. Your
scaffolding just gets in the way of
these models. And the question really
isn't how fancy is your agent stack.
Increasingly, it's how strong is the
model driving it.
And the lesson here is relentless. Um, a
perfect example of what I'm talking
about is Gemini 3.0 released this week
and it immediately dominated terminal
bench leaderboards with no aentic
harness supporting it at all. In this
chart, you can see Gemini 3.0 on
Terminus scored better than the vast
majority of model agent combinations in
the world all out of the box. And what's
remarkable is that Terminus is designed
to be an unopinionated generic stripped
down harness. And it has no graph
search, no rag, no indexing, just here's
a terminal, go figure it out. And it
crushes. The whole point of terminus is
that it has no clever tool calling, no
context engineering features. So the
takeaway here is that capability beats
scaffolding. If you get out of the
model's way, it will perform just fine.
So really what I'm driving at and the
key takeaway from this whole talk is if
you're building agents, just relax. Cool
it with all your clever engineering
tricks. Stop overthinking it. That's it.
That's the lesson. And another point on
this, kind of like an aside, is I don't
know about you guys, but we're all on
Twitter. I'm on Twitter, and at this
point, I just think talking about these
like clever little context tricks and
and hacks is a little played out. Like,
at this point, I'm straight up tired of
seeing some of this stuff. And like, I
get it. it's free engagement and we all,
you know, indulge in it a little bit.
But personally, I think there's not
really much signal there.
So, if you want the full playbook for
building an effective coding agent, like
the playbook's right here. It's up on
the screen. Um, there's really some
novelty talking about it like months
ago, but at this point, in my opinion,
it's been done to death. And we've been
in this, you know, we're model agnostic
at Klein. We support all the models.
Every two weeks there's a new big model
release going out and we've basically
come down to the same playbook of
supporting each model as it comes out.
So I'm sure everyone here knows how to
tune an agent from Sonnet 4 to Sonnet
4.5, from Gemini 2.5 to Gemini 3 and GBT
5 to GP GBT 5.1. I feel like this entire
conversation is a little played out. So,
I'm not really even going to cover this
in depth because the tweaks here are
trivial and the gains are marginal.
So, what I really want to talk about is
something that's not actually given a
lot of attention and it's the real
bottleneck. And the real bottleneck is
that you can build the cleanest agent in
the world, but that doesn't improve
model capability by even 1%. Models only
get better when labs train on something
hard. And benchmarks, not agent
cleverness, not all your clever
engineering techniques, not your clever
rag pipelines. It's benchmarks that
determine what frontier models learn to
do next. And models didn't magically get
better at tool use.
They got better because people built RL
environments that forced them to
practice certain actions. handling
failure more handling failure modes
retrying and for example like agents
improve only when the model learns
inside the right environment every jump
in reasoning we've seen came from a
benchmark every jump in agent
reliability came from an RL environment
so the real questions become what is a
benchmark how do you turn real world
agent coding data into an RL environment
and what makes a good verifier how do
you detect [clears throat] real
difficult ulty and how do you train
these models to work on the problems
that we actually care about as
engineers? These are the questions that
matter for the next frontier.
So what is a benchmark?
A benchmark put simply it's an
environment. It's a so in our case it's
like a docker container where you let
the agent run wild. It's a starting
state which is the snapshot of the code
when you started working on a real world
coding task as well as a starting
prompt. And the last thing is a verifier
at the end that checks whether an end
state is correct or acceptable.
So how are RL environments different?
[clears throat]
Well, here's the thing. They're not
really different at all. And you might
notice this chart is basically the same
thing as the previous slide. The only
real difference, the only distinction
here is how the reward is used.
Benchmarks measure models. RL
environments improve models. The score
doesn't just stop in a leaderboard where
you publish the results. The score is
actually used to update the weights of
the policy model.
So, how do you transform real world
coding data into useful RL environments
for training?
At Klein, we created the system called
an RL environments factory. Looking for
a better name there, but that's what we
got so far. And the first phase in this
pipeline is you get sub agents and you
have them qualify tasks. And these sub
agents, they work in parallel to decide
whether or not given tasks are suitable
to be turned into RL environments for
the purpose of training.
And the qualification process goes as
follows. So you have you start with
origins. So you have to validate does
the repository actually exist. Is the
starting commit accessible? Is it open
source? The journey where you look at
the starting prompt, the other follow-on
prompts that the user might have
followed up with with the agent. You
have to try to understand what was the
user actually trying to accomplish, what
was the spirit of their task. And
lastly, it's the outcome. So, can we
find the actual commits or PRs that fix
the problem in real life? Like, did they
actually commit the solution to their
problem later on in the timeline? And
we're actively looking for easy
disqualifiers as part of this. So,
things like vibecoded slop, we don't
need another benchmark that tests for,
you know, build the next.js app uh from
scratch. We're looking we're looking to
disqualify trivial tasks that are too
easy and tasks that have no reliable
start or end states.
And lastly, what makes a good RL
environment good? How do we actually
make an RL environment and what makes a
good test or verifier?
So phase two of this pipeline is
building the actual RL environment. So
you start out with archaeology where you
actually reconstruct both states
locally. You pull down the code, you see
if you can implement it yourself,
reconstruct it, build it, and verify
that the bug that the user was
referencing and the solution actually
exists. You document every obstacle and
dependency. You containerize it with
Docker, removing Git obviously, so
agents can't reward hack. And lastly,
you define the verifier at the end. And
this is where it gets into like a little
bit of the art of building a good
verifier. And I want to talk about this
because the analogy that I typically
give is a teac kettle. So let's say the
user's goal is I want to boil water.
A really good example of a verifier to
test whether or not the water is boiling
is a little whistle attachment that goes
inside your teac kettle. And the whistle
is a pure outcome verification. And it's
an example of a pure outcome driven
verifier where the water either reached
the boiling point or it didn't. Either
it's whistling or it's not. The kettle
doesn't care how you achieved it,
whether you used a gas stove, an
electric induction stove, or a campfire.
It just signals the result. And in the
process of doing this, all these weird
bad tests can emerge. So you might have
noticed like that the sub agent might
have noticed like oh in the ground truth
solution like in a previous run the
burner was set to high so maybe we
should be checking for that but we all
know that water can boil at a low
setting on the burner or was it on the
front left burner has 5 minutes elapsed
like all kinds of weird bad tests and
the key point here is don't
overprescribe based on the ground truth
test for the spirit of the task test for
the outcome of the task.
And the outcome at the end of all this
is a containerized benchmark or
environment for that task. Agent work is
recorded so you can see the traces the
trajectory that the agent took to
complete the task and you can reliably
score it and verify it and it's fully
portable. You can run it on any device.
So the path to automation that we've
been undertaking as part of this is can
we fully automate the process of
converting real world coding data into
RL environments for the purpose of
training models.
And this work largely started out manual
but then the first time in the RL
environment was like about 16 hours of
my time. And what used to take 16 hours
now takes less than 20 minutes per task.
And we're building towards a fully
automated RL environment factory where
the bottleneck shifts from engineering
to collecting high quality tasks. And an
interesting kind of point here, the
natural endpoint of all this is what if
we actually built RL environments and
this is like a question for everyone in
the audience is what if we built RL
environments to test how well agents can
actually make RL environments kind of
like a meta benchmark. What would hill
climbing on that look like? And you can
kind of start imagining that as models
get really really good at making their
own RL environments to train on based on
real world user data, you kind of
complete that loop. Something to think
about. So, okay. Um, this next part is
the truth nuke. Um, also known as TRO.
Um,
an unspoken fact is that we're not alone
at Klein building this kind of system.
Every major agent lab captures this
data. They all do some version of this
behind the scenes, but no one really
talks about it. And I don't even need to
name them. If you know, you know. And
realistically, you all know. These same
companies site internal benchmarks to
justify legacy systems that they spent
months maintaining. But curiously,
you'll never be able to study or inspect
them because they don't publish them
openly. And this data is so valuable yet
no one shares it. It's the only thing
that actually moves the needle.
And here's the heart of my argument is
by standing between real world engineers
working on real world tasks and the
models agent labs have a unique role in
history. We can build better prompts. We
can build better tools. But none of that
improves the underlying models. We
possess the single richest data set of
real engineering work anywhere in the
world. Models don't improve without this
data and keeping them closed is slowing
down Frontier Research.
So today we're announcing client bench.
This is our attempt to finally create a
benchmark that isn't cosplay
engineering. It's not write me a server
that generates Fibonacci sequences. This
is real software development captured
and packaged into standardized RL and
inval and eval environments and this is
the benchmark that we always wanted
someone else to build. No one did. So
we're doing it and anyone can
participate. So here's how it works. The
whole thing is open source. There's no
secret sauce, no locked away data sets.
You can openly run it yourself and
inspect it to see how it works. Anyone
can use these environments for SFT, RL,
eval, whatever. The point is is to just
give the entire ecosystem a real
substrate to measure and improve models
on, not just leak code puzzles. And this
only works if the community contributes.
And the good news is you don't actually
need to do anything special. Just work
on your open source project with the
client provider turned on and opt into
the client bench initiative. If a
frontier model gets stuck and you step
in to fix it, that's actually a ideal
task for to be a candidate for a
benchmark and that's it. Just use the
climb provider, see where the model
struggles and we'll pick it up and
introduce it into this open-source
benchmark. So, client bench will always
remain free, fully open source and
freely accessible.
Thank you all. If you want to
contribute,
[music]
>> [music]